hi everyone I'm Jeff and here I have a
Shashi Gowda and Josh day with me good
to see all of you so out of curiosity
how many people have heard of Julia okay
great how many people have tried at
least try - Julia okay a few people
that's good so just as a very quick
review so I'm gonna talk a bit about
just very a very high-level why we
created the language Julia and then
we're mostly going to talk about this
new project Julia DB so we had this blog
post about addressing the all-important
question of why we might need another
language you can check that out if you
want more details but basically we
created Julia to address what we call
the two language problem where you
essentially need different languages for
prototyping and productivity versus
deployment and performance and you see
this nowadays in that many are and
Python packages are actually written in
C and C++ and because you need that to
get performance so we saw this as a
problem we said you know what we want
one language that can do all of this and
so we designed julia to be able to do
that so the dream is to be at least as
nice as the productivity languages
python or matlab but as fast as C in
Fortran and we we did this in kind of a
we know what I consider kind of a
principled way by not just sort of
taking the same thing and just kind of
trying to speed it up but rethinking the
design from the beginning in a way that
would just naturally lead to a nicer
architecture and naturally lead to
performance and there's gonna be a
tutorial about it giving an intro to the
language on Thursday and you can find
out a bit about how to use it and how it
works so basically we have a JIT
compiler the paradigm of the language is
multiple dispatch so you can overload
functions on all the arguments instead
of just the receiver or just the first
argument and there is a type system that
can be useful for adding expressiveness
to programs there's a lot of support for
meta programming for generating code
which is often needed for performance
and for certain hard problems we have
been very into parallelism from the
beginning we've had a distributed
parallelism module in the standard
library from the beginning and when you
put all these things together I think
actually very interesting things become
possible and in particular with the
combination of features that we had and
the abilities to have both the easy
language and the fast language in the
same package this turns out to be I
think a really interesting language to
write a database in and one of the
reasons is that with the expressive
types that julia has they turned to be i
turn out to be useful for describing
essentially schemas and then you feed
that into our compiler and you kind of
automatically get optimized code for
various different queries and
combinations of data types and so we
realized we could use this to make a an
interesting data system and so we've
recently released this as open source
and it's called julia DB and these guys
are going to tell you a bit more about
it alright so introducing julia DB here
so the first question is like why do we
want this to exist what are we making
and so the idea is that like we
shouldn't have to glue together existing
tools like to get performance so kind of
why like Jeff talked about Julia was
being designed from scratch instead of
just like building off of Python we're
kind of building something new as
opposed to trying to glue things
together so on github if you go to
various projects repos there's this
little bar that you can click and it
shows the percentage of files are that
are associated with certain languages so
here is pandas and you can see it's a
big chunk of that it's Python and it's
hard to say what percentage of that is
actually seith on there's some HTML some
C we can look at a deeply r4r and so
that is you know 57% are left with a big
chunk of C++ another big our package is
data table which has a lot of features
to ours built-in data frames so that's
actually more C than is R and then
compare that finally with what we have
in julia DB which is just 100% julia so
yeah everything in julia to be we're not
tacking things together we're kinda
building it from scratch and just taking
advantage of the type system and the JIT
to get to get specialized code so the
goals here are to bring the promise of
Julia to data science
we're trying to you know solve this two
language problem and we want to be able
to efficiently work with you know
persistent data sets that are stored in
multiple files we want queries and user
to find functions to be fast so again
we're leveraging the JIT so that our
user functions are just as fast as the
stuff that's built in and we also want
Julie to be to perform the heavy lifting
of distributed computing so if I flip
the switch and say add more processes
Julie to B should be able to take care
of that and speed things up for me
without me doing a lot of manual work
and then another kind of philosophy
behind this is that batteries are
included so we have tools for analytics
and just tools for working with data so
as a quick example of just loading data
here since we're in New York so I looked
at this New York City taxicab data so
this is just looking at yellow cabs and
I'm looking at the first four months of
data for 2017 so these four CSV files
make out about 3.2 gigs
one file per month and if I just look at
the head of these files so I think it's
17 columns I'm gonna set indexes by the
first two things so vendor ID and the
pickup time so it gives the the pickup
time the drop-off time and the fare and
the tip for every ride in the first
couple months of this year so it's
really to be I just need to really load
this data kind of ingest at once so if I
call Edie procs and Julia it's
automatically automatically going to add
as many processes as I have cores
available and then I'm gonna use Julie
DB I'm gonna set the path to my data and
then when I call this low table function
it's going to load or attempt to load
every single CSV file that's in that
directory and I'm setting the columns
that I want to index by is the first two
things now I can save this for later
usage so once I save this database as my
data I can start a new Julia session and
when I go to load this it's just nearly
instantaneous so we're looking at a data
set and so here's about 40 million
observations and it's running on on four
processors at the moment we can see so
Julia automatically gets this type
information from all the columns and
it's I hardly did any manual work to
this and Julia DB just takes care
a lot of that so now we have our data
loaded so we want to be able to do
things with it so I'm the author of this
package called online stats and the idea
is that it uses online algorithms so
nothing to do with the internet but it's
that its input gets entered piece by
piece
so each statistic or model inside this
package is its own type and everything
gets updated one observation at a time
and so online stats is part of this
batteries included philosophy so you can
automatically do a bunch of different
summary statistics like means and
covariance matrices and approximate
quantiles things like density estimation
with histograms you can do things like
regression in a closed form so you can
get exact regression estimates even if
it's even if you're estimating it online
and then you can also do it approximate
penalize as generalized linear models so
there's a variety of different
algorithms and losses and penalties that
you can plug in and all this stuff gets
compiled really well just because Julie
is depending on the jet and multiple
dispatch to to do all these things
there's a couple unique features or
online stats that I haven't seen
anywhere else and so one of these things
is just the ability to plug in different
weighting types so somene is a type in
online stats and you can plug in
different ways to weight this thing so
an exponentially weighted mean gives
every single observation just a constant
value so if I give everything a weight
of 0.1 so this this red line here is an
exponentially weighted mean so if this
is parameter drift or depending on who
you ask that's called non-stationarity
or concept drift so if i our true model
is changing over time and equally
weighted me and won't be able to capture
that and exponentially we exponentially
weighted mean will be able to so this is
a very like simple case but like this
will also happen with like linear
regression and more complicated models
so you can also adapt your data and then
also calculations can be done in
parallel so just like I said angel you
to be I want to be able to just like
flip the switch and it's going to do
things distributed for me and
essentially it's able to do that with
online staffs because online stats can
do things like embarrassingly parallel
so if I have some statistic that I give
these three values another one I give
these three values another one these
these three green ones I can merge them
all at the end and
just exactly equivalent to giving one of
these statistics all these observations
in the row
so essentially Julie to be knows how to
like manage this so so again we flipped
that switch to say do this distributed
it knows how to run things through and
how many steps to make and then how to
merge them at the end so that the user
actually doesn't see any of this going
on
alright so here I'm just loading the
plots library and Julia and online stats
and I'm going to produce images with
plotly just so that they're interactive
so one of the main operations Angelita
be is this reduce so I can give it any
julia function so that plus is just a
normal function in julia if i want to
calculate a mean say I want to select
fair amount from this thing and divide
it by its length so the average fair is
$12 70 cents so again so mean isn't is a
type of online set I can also reduce by
this mean type it's going to spit out
that value for me it's a little bit more
interesting things so say I want to look
at just the distribution of the number
of passengers in this first couple
months so fit categorical is the type in
online stats where it essentially holds
a dictionary of each level and it also
is going to add in the count of each
thing that we see so I'm selecting
passenger count and I know that that
column is an in 64 so I'm telling fit
categorical that's what it is and this
runs through so again we're looking at
like 40 million observations so this
runs through fairly quick and we can get
that categorical distribution of the
number of passengers if we want to look
at things like continuous variables so
histograms are you know common types for
that so here I want to look at two
columns so I'm going to select the fare
amount and the tip amount from this
database and I'm giving it to histogram
objects and that's because I'm looking
at two different things
and then I can plot these at the end so
those actually a little bit curious
about why there is this bump here at the
end but so maybe some of you experience
this there's a fixed price if you take a
taxi from JFK to anywhere in Manhattan
which is $52 that's why there's this
spike right there yeah
and now I'm gonna hand laughter chachi
okay so benchmarks
how does jr. a beeper perform compared
to so we basically benchmarked against
find us
so in this plot we are plotting the
performance relative to panda find us so
one is basically the speed of pandas so
if any point is below that that means
it's faster these benchmarks are faster
if any point is about that that means
that it's slower so some of the some of
these points are below one we're like I
think most of them so we have fast
joints and then loading CSV is pretty
fast and then just doing aggregates is
pretty fast and there are a few things
that we are working on which are not yet
there but things are within two or three
times the performance finder find us so
yeah so more detail about performance
yeah it took twice as much time so yeah
more numbers so reading CSV we worked on
this quite a bit to make it fast and we
can get a pretty good speed on this data
set New York taxi data set so I was
trying this out and I realized that
pandas is reading date strings so I also
advanced back that in jr. and it turns
out reading string dates as strings is
actually slower because it keeps
allocating the string well in pandas it
takes longer it takes a it's faster
actually so that is just to show that
date but date time parsing is a pretty
fast in Julia sir
so group by benchmarks so there's one
benchmark where it's it's like twice as
low compared to find us this is because
so this is basically counting the
abrogating the count of number of
observations by day of week comma
passenger count and the floor of trip
distance sorry yeah yeah so in this
benchmark it's all a single thread um so
this floor function actually returns a
float so we don't switch to the off end
sorting at that point because we
consider floats as conceived continuous
variables but if I did floor of int then
it's the performance is kind of
comparable to fund us so most of these
things are comparable so these are
joined benchmark so we julia DB performs
comparable to pandas but in one case
where we're using string keys to string
keys it's it's it's it's a bit slower I
think we find us might be doing some
kind of interning or you know pooled
arrays type of stuff I think we can also
get just those be fast so a bit about
the benchmark it has 80,000 keys out of
which a 8,000 keys are unique and then
on the left side and on the right side
there are 8,000 keys out of which six
six thousand of them are present on the
left table so it's like a many to one
joint so we we have two types of tables
one with strings as the keys and one
with floating point sources as the keys
so this benchmark was actually done by
West McKinney I took it from his blog
and then repeated it in Julia so okay so
a bit more about this this is so far
I've spoken about the benchmarks I'll be
talking about the API right API now so
we have two data structures one is a
table which is like a collection of rows
if we treat it as a collection of rows
and you can have it ordered by some of
the
it's good for this is good for like data
science II workloads and there is
another type called nd sparse it stands
for n dimensional sparse array which
behaves more like an n dimensional array
and it's good for like more scientific
kind of workload where the data is
regular like a signal processing and
stuff like that so these are the
functions we have in today DB and they
all work on both the table and n
dispersed structure both in distributed
and and in serial so you have the usual
suspect select map filter drop and airy
columns rows and then some functions for
manipulating columns and then grew
reduce group reduce group by a flatten
and then we have joined group join as of
join in much merge is basically
concatenate I can crank I connect
concatenation and then we have so L save
and load functions which can save tables
basically already there are some
functions which are specific to the data
structure so first one is load table
which is which just loads the table is
and the second one the once which is
specific to nd sparse are here so nd
sparse behaves like a key value pair so
you can get the keys select the keys and
then it also behaves like an array which
I'll get into right now so so the focus
in the in the API is more on having
reusable conventions rather than you
know having a ton of options in each
function so an example is the Select
operation so in this slide what you are
seeing is this is the code that gets run
this is the code that gets run and this
is the output of the code and this is
the table the TBL variable is this table
so I'm so saying select T V of X will
return a vector which is that column and
then saying a tuple of column names will
return a new table with only those
columns and then saying
this column name and giving it a
function will return will apply the
function to each element of that and
then saying this which says select these
two fields and then apply this function
on those for those two fields so it's
it's calculating the high pot which is
like the hypotenuse of x and y so that
will give you a vector where each
element is transformed this way and
giving it a vector just returns the
vector it has to be the same length as
the table and finally you can you can
give it like a custom column so it gives
back a table with that custom call and
then there's more you can you can
combine that combine any of these in the
triples to get like more complicated
things to work so this is the select
operation now this is you can actually
use these selectors in all of these
operations so including Map Reduce
filter group by groupings and so on so
to select any custom part of your data
to work with so for example enjoy and
you can say I want to are say in group
radius you can say I want to group by
the day of week of a certain date time
column and it will just work so so
that's how we've made the API so a bit
more about the in dispatch structure I
so far I spoke about the table data
structure but any in dispersed is more
like an n dimensional array but the
indexes are not integers there can be
any arbitrary data types which can be
ordered so in this case I'm loading a
data set of of currency pairs and their
bid and ask values at any in 2016
December so I'm loading five files six
million observations so here you can see
there's a vertical line here everything
to the left of a left of the line
consists the index so this this data is
indexed by aud/jpy and
the time and then on the right is the
data so if we can look more into into it
so X is my index table so if you say key
type he'll tell you the key it's keyed
by string and date time and if you see
the L type which is the elephant type it
will tell you it's a named tuple of bit
and ask values so you can index into
this using the values itself so you can
say give me the data for AUD /jp why at
this time point so it will give you that
it returns a named tuple so but you can
also convert this into a table a
relational table and if you see the L
type of that it includes the pair and
time fields as well because it's it just
iterates for Pyro's so if you index into
the first row you'll get the first row
rather the end of just the thing on the
right side so you can also do like range
selection so you can say give me all the
values for these dates so this is an
interval these dates for all for all the
currency pets or you can say you can
restrict the currency pairs you can say
only Australian dollars University and
CID - JPY for these dates so it'll give
you that slice of the data in others
okay and you can so an indexed nd sparse
is most useful when you have so if you
see the L type of this it says - field
name tuples so the name tuples are bid
and ask free has bid and ask fields but
it's an ND sparse is most useful when
you just have you know as a plain type
like a float64 so in this case I'm
taking out a bid bid column into a new
nd sparse so I get this so if I index
into that if I see the L type of the
it's just a floating point now I can use
array operations on it like reduced m
which is like a generic
function in Julia for all arrays you say
you can say drop the second dimension
which is the date and then aggregate the
result by plus so it's going to add up
add up all the values in the bits for
every currency pair we have so you can
also convert a dimension by saying okay
convert the time dimension by truncating
it to the our nearest hour and then
aggregate any any values in the same
hour by doing a max operation so it's
getting the maximum for every hour and
then you have this new index table like
this in these powers like this so here
here I'm taking out the hourly data for
only AUD / j py there now what I can do
with this is I can do a broadcast kind
of operation so if you wanted to divide
all all the data points using this data
point for the aud/jpy for that hour you
can just do dot slash aud/jpy and it
kind of does a broadcast for each
currency fare so you can see that for if
here we have only once that is because
it's dividing it by itself but for the
others it's dividing it by the dollar
yen value so this this this is called a
broadcast in julia and it's not some
special thing you can give it any
user-defined function you can say
broadcast instead of / i'm saying hi pod
here so find the hypotenuse like the
distance between those two so it can do
that as well so in summary an Indies
pass is indexed by any arbitrary keys in
this case we saw like a time series
example and you can index it by
intervals of values iterates by values
behaves like multi-dimensional arrays
and supports array syntax like broadcast
reduced in MapReduce and stuff this is a
great for representing any type of
series especially time series
yes so this is what we have planned next
for Julia DB so we are working on
feature extraction for machine learning
and kind of batched machine learning
algorithms so that's coming coming
through and we want to have more
comprehensive out of code support like
right now you can do online stats out of
code which means that you can have more
data than that fits in your RAM and
it'll just handle that and we are
working on having dents in dimensional
data store for example you may have
satellite imagery where it's basically
indexed by XYZ coordinates and then over
time and it may have RGB channels so you
want to be able to work with that of the
that kind of headset and then we want to
work on streaming updates so something
like a streaming data frame which which
will work very well with online stats so
that's the end of the talk thanks
everyone these are our email addresses
if you have any questions please do
email us and then you can go to Julia DB
dot org for the website Thanks yeah yeah
so Julia actually has both so we the
distributed has kind of always been
there and we have now increasingly we
have credit supports as well so it does
both
[Music]
so overall at the outer level it's like
a multi-process model I'll pick a Z
general oh yeah yeah so at the outer
level it's real it's it's more of a
multi processing model because in
general you will have really really big
datasets and so people want to scale
onto multiple machines so that's that's
you that's mostly what it is within us
if you have like a single machine with a
lot of processors and a lot of memory it
can also work on that by just doing
essentially the same thing within that
box that's right yeah so right now it
uses what you might call like a like a
peer kind of API where you're you're
programming directly to the system the
query language and the programming
language and the and the database code
itself is sort of one single system that
you're working with in the future you
know in any database can do
client-server right because you can own
whatever you're typing at the prompt you
might as well just send over the wire
and send back the results so we have we
don't have that style of API yet but I
imagine we will need it in some point in
the future and we'll add a client-server
mode at some point probably but we don't
have it yet any other questions so you
say DPA in-memory DB or instead is it oh
I mean like Oracle outside it can it can
store the disk as well yeah it handles
it handle storage as well so it's
persistent so it's so well we do have
out of core support so so essentially it
doesn't have to be entirely in memory
the without of core the performance is
not very good right now it's in general
you want to have enough memory to hold
whatever you're working on or you're not
going to get great performance so
we're kind of working on that but it's
yeah out of course it's kind of tricky
to get it to really be fast when you're
reading from disk resisting to disk sort
of file formats do you support I think
you showed CSV but you guys have or plan
to support like park' or like an HD 5 or
something
not CSV yeah that's a good question so
right now we use basically CSV and our
own binary format which we use basically
to make data and mapable so it's just a
more efficient binary format that's
really way way more efficient we are
looking at using something like park'
which we think will have a similar
benefit but is more standard so we're
yet we're planning to probably add
parkade support and maybe some other
things and can you talk a little bit
about like the memory format that's used
by Judah TB a zero-based com based is
customized format or something more
standard it's column based essentially
but it's just a specific format to
Juliet it's I mean it's not as it's not
particularly weird it's you know like if
you have a array of random
floating-point numbers it's just a
floating point array like any other
system so it's not too strange we will
also do the standard tricks like storing
especially storing arrays with few
unique values and which are you know
standard database kinds of techniques
that pandas also uses well we will use
some of those specialized column
representations you know compressed
column representations as well but it's
nothing too exotic yeah kind of Thanks
is there any planned integration with
pandas directly so like convert a
jubilee TP table to a panda's data frame
or vice versa
I think probably I think I don't think
it would be too hard to do because julia
python Interop is generally very good so
I think it would be quite possible I
could do that
we try to do that actually in the in the
a while ago but there was like and we
felt like there was no not enough
support for user-defined types that we
created in Syria that you want to also
store in your data oh yeah that's that's
also a really good point is that one
thing about this is every julia data
type just automatically works so you can
define a new data type and it can store
it immediately and people have actually
done this a lot so there are a lot of
interesting data types in julia like for
currencies and dates of various sorts
and even things like colors and units
physical units on things all kinds of
exotic types like that and they will it
can just be handled natively with full
performance so if you have stuff like
that in there then it's difficult to to
transfer to like pandas but for standard
data types we could do it pretty easily
yeah so there is a units package that
can do that and you could store unit
quantities in the database and there's
actually there there's a neat currency
types package in julia that will even it
will do with things like arithmetic but
you know if you add one dollar plus one
pound you get back out a currency basket
that still has both because the exchange
rate changes you can't just add them
together so there's actually julia
package that does that and you can use
that with this so how would you compare
like julia solution for addy sparse i'm
just interested in particularly in
arbitrary indexing and using julia DB
for that which is my use case versus
like the python alternative doing it
well what i think is like to skew pi
which could o ind sparse mmm
it's I guess the main difference is that
it's distributed built-in distributed
and I think it's much more flexible in
what the indexes can be because the
index can be in julia DB can be any type
that has a total order
okay would you say like this is like the
a unique thing that Julie DB offers it
it's probably not globally unique but
it's it's slightly unusual I guess okay
thanks
you know the questions yeah okay I'll
use it anyway
so you guys use pandas as a comp I've
never actually dealt with storing data
and pandas unless I was pulling it back
from a source wouldn't sparc be a better
comp and how do you guys comp to spark
oh sure we should do benchmarks against
that as well okay um but I'm actually
talking about the depth of the machine
learning library it's one of the
problems you run into and you get into
distributed a temp set coupling both
languages together is usually your
library of models diminishes pretty
significantly because it's pretty
difficult to apply those across multi
node problems so how would you compare I
know I don't know how familiar you guys
are with it like when it comes to the
types of available Ensemble models like
do you guys have a similar complement of
neural networks so on and so forth
random forests the tree ensembles that
you'd see in say scikit-learn okay so
yeah in learning it's a good question so
I think this is you know that this is
this whole area is a good example of why
in my view you need a lot of generality
because you know what we've had in the
past is somebody makes a big data system
but they weren't thinking about machine
learning the machine learning has to be
done in some other language and now
you're faced with having to put them
together and it's annoying so this is
exactly where you need a system with
more generality in my view in there
there are Julie on machine learning
packages so we've done things like
taking you know taking very large tables
and using machine learning techniques on
it in distributed memory because it
makes it easy to do that I don't think
we have an exactly comparable set of
models as scikit-learn I don't think we
have as much at this point but you could
probably you know if you really needed
to you could run Python inside of it
which would which would be a little bit
defeat the purpose but there are there
are some really really good giulia
machine learning packages like quenette
and flux are the names of them
anything else I should mention mocha
there's mocha so these these are really
good machine learning frameworks so
they'd be like the ML Lib comps and
spark so be a good one to compare okay
cuz the only reason I'm asking is we use
spark and that was one of the reasons
check this out as a potential
alternative target self as downfalls as
well yeah so we have those packages
exist in the Julian ecosystem but I
don't think it's you know the coverage
is exactly the same Thanks yeah one more
question
Oh what's the 1.0 story they really
quickly julia 1.0 story is we have a
feature freeze coming up on december
15th and then that will basically be it
we will go through the normal release
process that will be 0.7 and then we
will just remove all the things that
were deprecated and very shortly after
that we'll have 1.0 so we're very close